now your problem is you're selfish no my  problem was I believed you loved me and  you're incapable of it I gave everything  to keep something that I never even had  in the first place I always thought you  was an introvert extrovert a what he's  shy he's always been shy it's all his  father's fault don't blame me it'd have  been strange regardless I said I think  I'm okay with strange God not him both  of you stop I'm not going to allow you  to talk to me like this anymore it's  about time you said that  but it I never told you how much I need  you  no no I love you  I always have always will  you write songs that millions of people  love and that's what's important you  just need to remember who you are and be  okay with it he doesn't know who he is  yes I do I'm not that Gilley's joy I  thought you already blight  I've been ready to I'd for years  knees and hug me  [Music]